so reading that paper I got really
excited really inspired so I've set a
third year project third year
undergraduate project and their job is
to analyze drum patterns but to do it
over a wider range of drum patterns that
are described in this paper and in
particular to take a different drama and
a different pattern similar in many ways
but much as I like Picaro as a drummer I
must admit that Michael McDonald song
doesn't quite do it for me
so we're gonna choose a drama and other
drummer who's recognized as possibly
arguably the best rock drummer in the
world
topped polls so many times in so many
German magazines and won so many awards
and that's Neil Peart from Rush there's
a song called or Russ a very famous rush
song called Tom Sawyer where it's the
same type of 16th know pattern so that
but with one hand he also plays it with
one hand so there are very many
similarities with the photography the
groove is different and how he chooses
to accent stuff is is different but the
same overall idea so at this point you
do not know how much I would like to be
able to turn around and see in this
corner we've got Neil parrot from Rush
we've got Sean Riley Sean Riley is going
to play the opening few bars of Tom
Sawyer to give you an idea of that drum
partner to give you an idea that growth
yeah interesting so what do we want from
you well if you think you can do a
better job than Sean or indeed if you
think you can do a better job than Neal
period or even if you don't think you
can do a better job but you're a drummer
and you'd like to help out science and
indeed you'd like to get your name in a
paper then what we want you to do is to
send in example samples of you drumming
the start of Tom Sawyer or indeed the
whole thing that's up to you the first
eight sixteen bars will be fine what
we're interested in is those
fluctuations were interested from drama
to drama let's look at this and see how
universal this effect is and we want you
to send in samples in terms of wave
files mp3s MIDI files whatever you like
to the email address it'll be down here
somewhere Brady or put it down there at
some point and also there'll be lots
more information available for your blog
Brady will have linked it down there as
well so I must admit okay as some of you
will remember might know I am a major
rush fan sort of it's sort of I must
have a coincidental because parity is
what is recognized as one of the best
drummers and the pattern fits in and the
whole analysis will work but it doesn't
harm not a tourist song I must admit and
also what a motivation for this video is
that for my birthday my wife and kids
got me arrow drums if you haven't come
across our forums yet go and Google it
now because they are they are just
fantastic they were developed by a
couple of PhD students Trinity College
Dublin and if you've got arrow drums
please send in samples because they're
one of the great things is that instead
of having a real physical surface with
arrow drums you're basically flailing
into air and we're very interested in
what difference that makes in the
response times what difference it makes
in the fluctuations how much of it is
due to your muscle response on your
motor system response and much of it is
due to the bounce back from the hi-hat
and the drums so I'm going to try and
play Tom Sawyer this should be good for
a laugh let's go so you put these
reflectors on your feet let's turn it up
just let me sort myself out for second
cuz for John students moved okay so I'm
well off damage